what we have now is a possibility of a
vaccine that is specially engineered
to be able to deal with the omicron
variant and that in turn
should lead to even greater protection
against it and against other variants
that are related to it
this is all good news okay what i wanted
to stress today
is how important it is that we continue
being active on two different fronts
here the first is to keep the
vaccinations going because they do
protect people from getting severely ill
and dying when they are affected by
these viruses there's some suggestion
that the vaccines will also give some
protection against long covered but i
also want to urge everyone to remember
this is still a dangerous virus we know
how to prevent spread so if we can
continue with our face masks with our
physical distancing and most of all with
respect for the virus that would be
really helpful we want to keep the
levels of virus down at the same time as
keeping the hospitals not overloaded
with cases and that's the strategy
inoculating five-year-olds in wales um
against covert 19 is that something that
should be rolled out further
well there's going to be constant
questions about how many uh uh how low
an age group you go to when you're
vaccinating children on the one hand
it's highly desirable to protect them on
the other hand there's constant question
as to whether or not there is the level
of risk in children that there is in
older people my own view is now that we
know that vaccines can give some
protection against long covid there is a
growing case for immunizing children and
so i i think that from my point of view
uh this is uh the direction to go in
um i'm just reading that the world
health organization's regional director
for europe
this was at the beginning of the month
on the 3rd of february saying that 30 of
all covert cases since the pandemic uh
began have been reported this year alone
and the european region recorded 12
million new cases in a week should we
really be in a position where we are
loosening off um what we've put in place
to try to protect ourselves from covert
given you know a third of cases this
year alone
well first of all it is
people who are going to deal with this
pandemic the virus is the problem and
people are the solution and more and
more now as i talk to even quite large
groups of people i realize that they are
making up their own minds as to how to
get on top of things and it is
absolutely not a good idea when cases
are as high as they are when the virus
is moving as rapidly as it is for the
restrictions that we've all applied so
carefully to be dropped please continue
wearing face masks continue physical
distancing it's the right thing to do
and whatever else you hear from other
sources i can assure you the world
health organization asks everyone to
maintain the caution because the virus
is really moving around a lot at the
moment and you do not want to let go of
the restrictions and to give the virus a
free ticket right now it's not the right
thing to do so yes kate you are right
maintain
personal precautions for the time being
there's too much virus around to let go
um two of the uh restrictions that um
are most impactful on people's everyday
lives lockdowns and travel bans are they
effective
well you know that in the world health
organization we say very clearly
lockdowns are last resort they really
are they're very crude basically you're
stopping everybody from moving and
you're requiring them to stay at home
instead we say
protect against this virus with good
quality surveillance and local responses
organized by district or similar public
health officials and we will continue
with that advice and we will very much
say
do lockdowns only when you absolutely
have to you've got nothing else to do in
the same way we're cautious about
mandates requiring people to get
vaccinated or else they lose their jobs
because we think they create divisions
in society and they we would much rather
say to everybody you're part of the
solution we're not going to give you
these very tough mandates but we are
going to ask you to work together to
work with authorities because we can
only deal with this virus by working
together